VOLUNTARILY TESTIFY BEFORE THE
HOUSE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
ANY OTHER CONGRESSIONAL
INQUIRIES.
THAT WILL BE INTERESTING.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, THANK YOU.
LET'S GET SOME ANALYSIS FROM
LEGAL SCHOLAR JONATHAN TURLEY OF
GEORGE WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
WHAT STRUCK YOU FROM TODAY'S
HEARING?
>> WHAT WAS REALLY INTERESTING
WAS THE DIFFERENT NARRATIVES,
THE FACT IS THE IG WAS NOT
LIKELY TO FIND THAT DECISIONS
WERE BASED ON BIAS.
BUT ALSO IT'S NOT TRUE THAT HE
DIDN'T FIND BIAS.
HE ACTUALLY FOUND A LOT OF BIAS.
IT'S JUST THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO
ASSUME THAT THE BIAS HE FOUND
WAS THE CAUSE OF DECISIONS TAKEN
BY THE FBI.
>> Bret: NOT HIS MANDATE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
UNLESS SOMEONE WAS GOING TO
CONFESS OR HELP OUT WITH AN
EMAIL DETAILING SOME CONSPIRACY,
THERE WASN'T GOING TO BE A
FINDING THAT BIAS DROVE THE
DECISIONS.
BUT THE REPUBLICANS WERE
CORRECT.
THE REPORT IS HEAVILY LADEN WITH
VERY DISTURBING BIAS, INCLUDING
FROM THE CHIEF INVESTIGATOR.
THE QUESTION IS THAT WASN'T HIS
MANDATE.
HE'S NOT GOING TO MAKE THOSE
ASSUMPTIONS, SO WHERE DO YOU GO
FROM HERE?
THE ANSWER IN THE CONSTITUTION
AS YOU GO TO CONGRESS.
CONGRESS HAS AN OVERSIGHT DUTY
TO LOOK INTO THIS.
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS ARE
SIMPLY NOT ANSWERED.
FOR EXAMPLE, LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS
CORRECT TO RAISE THE ISSUE OF
CLINTON'S I.T. EXPERT WHO WAS
ACCUSED OF LYING REPEATEDLY TO
THE FBI, SCRUBBING HER SERVER
AFTER BEING TOLD IT WAS PART OF
AN INVESTIGATION AND SOMETHING
CONGRESS WAS LOOKING FOR AND
TOOK ALL THESE ACTIONS THAT
WOULD HAVE JUSTIFIED, AND MOST
OF OUR VIEW, AN ACTUAL CRIMINAL
CHARGE.
INSTEAD THEY GIVE HIM IMMUNITY
WHICH AT THE TIME LEFT ALL OF US
AS DUMBFOUNDED AS TO WHY YOU
WOULD POSSIBLY DO THIS.
THOSE QUESTIONS AREN'T ANSWERED
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THE MANDATE.
>> Bret: AFTER READING THE IG
REPORT AND SEEN THE TESTIMONY,
THE CASE FOR THE OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
>> THIS IG REPORT MAKES IT
DIFFICULT OBSTRUCTION CLAIM
BASED ON THE COMEY FIRING
VIRTUALLY INCONCEIVABLE.
YOU HAVE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
SAYING THAT COMEY WAS
INSUBORDINATE.
50 DEVIATED FROM POLICIES, THAT
THESE WERE SERIOUS VIOLATIONS.
FBI DIRECTOR ECHOED THAT.
GOOD REASONS TO FIRE HIM.
UNLESS YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS THAT TRUMP ACTED FOR
EVERY WRONG REASON INSTEAD OF
THE OBVIOUS RIGHT ONES, IT'S
GOING TO BE REAL HARD TO MAKE
OUT A CRIMINAL CASE.
>> Bret: THERE WERE OTHER
TEASES OF THINGS TO COME,
ANOTHER IG REPORT.
SOUNDED LIKE SEVERAL LEAK
INVESTIGATION INTO COMEY'S
PERSONAL USE OF EMAIL AND
WHETHER THERE WAS CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL THERE.
>> IF I WAS COMEY, I WOULD HEAR
A WHISTLE ON THE TRACK.
WE ARE LOOKING AT HIS REMOVING
THESE MEMOS FROM THE FBI WHICH
I'VE SAID FROM THE BEGINNING IS
CLEARLY FBI MATERIAL.
THE FBI HAS INDICATED THAT.
ONE MIGHT OF HAD CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IN IT.
I CAN IMAGINE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL SAYING OKAY,
THAT'S FINE.
FEEL YOU CAN REMOVE ANY FILES
YOU WANT AND LICK THEM TO THE
MEDIA.
THAT TRAIN IS GOING TO COME AND
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE GOOD FOR
COMEY.
>> Bret: THE FIRST STORY AND
THE ONE THAT'S GOTTEN A LOT OF
ATTENTION, WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING, WHAT
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING, WHAT
CONGRESS CAN OR SHOULD DO ON
THIS CASE WITH SEPARATING
PARENTS AND CHILDREN ALONG THE
BORDER.
>> IT'S A SAD STORY BECAUSE AS
USUAL IN WASHINGTON, THERE IS
TRUTH AND FALSITY ON BOTH SIDES.
EVERYONE SPINNING THIS AND IN
THE MIDDLE ARE THESE KIDS.
THE FACT IS THE ADMINISTRATION
DOES NOT HAVE TO SEPARATE THE
KIDS FROM THEIR MOTHERS.
THAT'S A CHOICE.
IT'S A POLICY CHOICE.
IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT THIS ISSUE
HAS BEEN FORCED BY A CHANGE IN
POLICY TO TREAT THESE AS
CRIMINAL MATTERS.
SOMETHING MANY CITIZENS SUPPORT.
DONALD TRUMP WAS BROUGHT TO
POWER BECAUSE HE PLEDGED TO GET
TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION.
GETTING TOUGH ON IMMIGRATION
MEANS TO SWITCH FROM A CIVIL OR
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS TO A
CRIMINAL ONE.
ONCE YOU DO THAT, YOU HAVE THESE
TYPE OF SEPARATION PROBLEMS.
THERE IS TRUTH ON BOTH SIDES.
THERE ARE SOME AGREEMENTS AND
SOME LAWS THAT GOVERN HOW LONG
AND UNDER WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES YOU
HOLD CHILDREN.
BUT CAN THE ADMINISTRATION KEEP
THESE FAMILIES TOGETHER?
I THINK THEY COULD.
>> Bret: THERE IS A CHOICE
THAT'S MADE AT THE BORDER THERE.
RICH LOWRY INDICATED IT IN A
OP-ED A COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
HE WROTE "U.S. MARSHALS TAKE
CUSTODY OF ADULTS AND CHILDREN
ARE HELD BY HHS.
PROSECUTION OF ADULTS USUALLY
HAPPENS QUICKLY.
IF THE ADULT WANTS TO RETURN
HOME, SHE OR HE IS REUNITED WITH
THEIR CHILD AND THEY ARE SENT
BACK TOGETHER.
WHERE IT GETS MORE COMPLICATED
IS IF I MIGRANT CLAIMS ASYLUM.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WAS TO
HOLD MIGRANTS PENDING
ADJUDICATION OF THOSE CASES.
IF THEY ARE RELEASED, THERE'S
GOOD GENES THEY WILL ABSCOND.
EVEN IF CASES ARE HANDLED
QUICKLY, THE GOVERNMENT HAS TO
RELEASE THE SOONER.
IT'S ONE OF THE DISTORTIONS THAT
MAKES RATIONAL POLICY OF THE
BORDER POLICY.
WHEN A COMPANY CHILDREN FROM
MEXICO ACROSS THE BORDER, WE CAN
TURN THEM HOME.
ANTITRAFFICKING LAW MAKES IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO THAT WITH
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA."
BASICALLY AS LONG AS MIGRANTS
KNOW THEY CAN GET IN, THEY WILL
KEEP COMING AND BRINGING THEIR
CHILDREN.
IF THEY CLAIM ASYLUM, THEY ARE
ESSENTIALLY CHOOSING TO SEPARATE
FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
>> I THINK IT'S DUE TO THE
PARADIGM SHIFT.
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS TREATING
THIS AS AN ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCESS, NOT A CRIMINAL ONE.
THERE WERE FEWER COMPLICATIONS.
ONCE YOU SHIFT TO AN ENFORCEMENT
SYSTEM, A CRIMINAL ONE, IT
MAGNIFIES THESE PROBLEMS.
BY THIS LAW DOES CREATE A
GLARING CONFLICT IN THIS 20 DAY
CLOCK.
YOU CAN RELEASE BUT THEN YOU
HAVE A GAP, MOTHER IS MOVING ON
A DIFFERENT TRACK FROM THE KID.
IT'S A LEGITIMATE ISSUE THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
RESOLVE.
>> Bret: SECRETARY NIELSEN
SAID THEY COULD GO TO A PORT OF
ENTRY AND CLAIM ASYLUM AND STAY
TOGETHER BUT THIS IS DEALING
WITH ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSING.
>> BOTH PARTIES ARE PLAYING
CHICKEN BUT THERE ARE KIDS IN
THE CAR.
I THINK EVERYONE'S GOING TO HAVE
TO A BREATHER, AND A RARE TIME
TO GET TOGETHER AND SAY LET'S
GET IT OFF THE TABLE.